si se logró este acuerdo de
480 mil millones de dólares de
endeudamiento extra hasta el 3 de
diciembre esto permitirá entonces que
eeuu pues pueda seguir cumpliendo sus
obligaciones financieras
dos meses más esto incluye también que
el gobierno de eeuu pueda seguir
haciendo pagos a la seguridad social de
los adultos mayores pagos a sus tropas
pagos a los veteranos y también pagos a
los beneficios de impuestos a las
familias permitirá también entonces que
una vez se apruebe este proyecto en el
senado en la cámara de representantes y
llegue entonces a despacho del
presidente yo bailé en esta tarde como
aspiran los senadores republicanos y
demócratas pues entonces la atención acá
en washington vuelva a centrarse en
aprobar el gran programa social de 3,5
billones de dólares y por ende el plan
de infraestructura